[Música]
se conocen las razones por las que el
fbi allanó la residencia del ex
presidente de honor joven florida el ex
mandatario habría retirado indebidamente
de la casa blanca' 15 cajas de
documentos entre los que había
información ultra secreta
la farmacéutica moderna demandó a sus
competidoras facer y el alemán a
bahiense que usando les de copiar su
tecnología a rn que fue empleada en la
vacuna contra el kobe 19 la medida legal
fue presentada tanto en eeuu como en
alemania
la agricultura cubana enfrenta a una
escasez el ministerio de agricultura
sostiene que la falta de tecnología y la
carencia de insumos básicos afecta a la
producción actualmente el país de hasta
2000 millones de dólares cada año para
importar alimentos
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en tras 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz empezamos en
estados unidos la fiscalía publicó una
versión editada del documento que
explica las motivaciones del fbi para
entrar en la residencia del ex
presidente de donald trump el pasado 8
de agosto según la nueva información
documentos clasificados que trump
entregó en enero a los archivos
nacionales fueron los que desencadenaron
la investigación contra el exmandatario
y motivaron la redada
después de días de presión mediática la
fiscalía estadounidense reveló el
documento que justifica la redada de la
casa del expresidente donald trump
hermana lago a inicios de agosto de 32
páginas 23 son ilegibles ya que se tachó
información que podría poner en riesgo
la investigación contra trump pero en
las páginas restantes se muestran las
razones que motivaron el allanamiento se
trata de 184 documentos clasificados
hallados en 15 cajas que trump entregó a
los archivos nacionales en enero pasado
después de haberlos retenido durante un
año entre estos documentos hay 67
confidenciales 92 secretos y 25 de
máximo secreto
este hallazgo de enero fue lo que
desencadenó la investigación y justificó
la redada en casa del ex presidente los
fiscales de la izquierda radical estar
manipulando con motivos políticos la ley
de documentos presidenciales bajo la que
no he hecho nada malo allanaron
ilegalmente mi casa y se llevaron cosas
que no deberían haberse llevado incluso
se metieron en mi caja fuerte algo
impensable
el documento revelado el viernes también
muestra que la defensa legal del ex
presidente intentó que la justicia no lo
investigara argumentando que se rompería
la separación constitucional de poderes
y que algunos de los archivos contenían
información confidencial sobre personas
que sirvieron como fuentes de
inteligencia a eeuu la casa blanca no
quiso pronunciarse más allá de esto no
diré nada porque no conozco los detalles
ni siquiera los quiero saber que el
departamento de justicia se encargue de
eso si la justicia encuentra suficientes
pruebas podría acusar a trump de
espionaje por el mal manejo de estos
documentos
la farmacéutica estadounidense moderna
denunció a facer y vayan check por haber
copiado sin permiso partes claves de su
tecnología de rn mensajero empleada en
el desarrollo de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19 moderna los acusa de haberla usado
para desarrollar su propia inoculación
moderna abrió una nueva batalla legal
sobre la tecnología de arn mensajero
esta vez denunciando a facer y bayón te
presentamos esta demanda para proteger
la innovadora plataforma de tecnología a
rn mensajero en la que fuimos pioneros
en la que invertimos miles de millones
de dólares para su creación y que
patentamos durante la década anterior a
la pandemia de kobe 19
la farmacéutica considera que facer y
variantes copiaron dos partes clave de
sus inventos primero una modificación
química particular sobre la rn que ayuda
a despertar una respuesta inmune
adecuada y segundo la codificación de
una parte de los corona virus que usan
para infectar las células y que es
necesario codificar para saber contra
qué debe protegerse el cuerpo sin
embargo vayan tec asegura que todas sus
invenciones son originales y también
fruto de años de investigación sobre la
rn mensajero una tecnología que se ha
usado comercialmente por primera vez
contra la pandemia de kobe 19 y que
podría abrir las puertas a nuevos
tratamientos por ejemplo contra el
cáncer
moderna prometió no implementar sus
patentes de la vacuna contra el commit
19 en los países de ingresos bajos y
medios pero desde marzo de este año
reclama que su propiedad intelectual se
respete en los países ricos hay un tema
financiero un tema de intercambio de
beneficios entre compañías y desde el
punto de vista de ciudadano yo estaría
muy tranquila moderna ha dejado muy
claro que no va a poner en peligro
acción de la vacuna esto es un tema muy
importante ni tampoco los beneficios en
países con pocos recursos
sólo en 2022 facer y bayonne tec se han
embolsado 22 mil millones de dólares por
su vacuna moderna casi 10 mil millones y
medio
en wyoming uno de los estados con menor
población de eeuu una comunidad de
vaqueros busca abrir nuevos espacios de
diálogo para evitar que más de sus
integrantes se suiciden al no tener con
quién hablar de sus problemas de salud
mental la historia la tiene juan pabló
lucumí
estos vaqueros se reúnen para hablar de
sus sentimientos
uno de los suyos murió de una sobredosis
en 2021 ahora han creado un espacio para
que ninguno se quede sin compartir sus
luchas adicciones o problemas de salud
mental en una comunidad que tiene
principalmente tradiciones machistas y
en donde las emociones siempre han
quedado en un segundo plano
se supone que los vaqueros son duros
hemos nacido y crecido para ser
independientes y no depender de nadie y
muchas de las cosas que hacemos son por
nuestra cuenta así que no tenemos esa
capacidad de comunicación para ir a otro
sitio y hablar y compartir nuestras
emociones y creo que muchos de nosotros
luchamos con eso
con vastas llanuras y montañas rocosas
wyoming y es el último bastión del oeste
de eeuu es el estado con la población
más baja del país con menos de 600.000
habitantes y su superficie representa el
doble de un país como grecia a
diferencia de las grandes ciudades no
cuentan con un sistema sólido para
atender adecuadamente los problemas de
salud mental
debido a la singularidad de wyoming ya
no tenemos los recursos que se
encuentran en otros estados no tenemos
un grupo masivo de proveedores de salud
mental en todo el estado y profesionales
para el tratamiento de los trastornos
por uso de sustancias
con cerca de 670 miembros en facebook la
iniciativa no más sillas vacías espera
desde la experiencia y el diálogo evitar
que muchas personas busquen una solución
a problemas en el suicidio se financian
con las donaciones de sus seguidores y
esperan que su causa resuene en todo el
país
en mexico miles de personas entre las
que se encontraban familiares de los 43
estudiantes de ayotzinapa se tomaron las
calles de la capital para exigir
justicia por la desaparición de sus
seres queridos la multitud pedía que se
castigue a los responsables y apuntaban
contra el ex presidente enrique peña
nieto- y altos mandos militares el caso
ocurrió el 26 de septiembre de 2014
cuando el grupo de alumnos intentaba
apoderarse de autobuses para viajar la
ciudad de méxico para participar de una
protesta
en cuba el gobierno ha intentado paliar
la crisis a la que se enfrenta debido a
la escasez de alimentos agravada por la
falta de insumos y la casi ausencia de
tecnificación del campo cuba importa
unos 2.000 millones de dólares en comida
una cifra de la que podrían ahorrarse
unos 800 se produjeran ellos mismos sus
productos andrés granadillo nos tiene
más en cuba' la crisis no da tregua los
agricultores como lázaro sánchez deben
sortear los problemas en los que está
sumida la isla este minuto muy
particular no tenemos combustible es una
situación difícil que es el país entero
no es que seamos nosotros sólo que
estamos afectados de 34 meses vamos a la
comida que teníamos que estar sembrando
y que no debemos comer dentro de cuatro
meses nos la vamos a tener la capacidad
de cultivar en su granja se ha visto
mermada además de la falta de
combustible debe encontrar semillas para
sembrar y aparecer en una lista del
gobierno para poder alquilar los
tractores del estado mientras los
agricultores tienen dificultades para
cosechar los habitantes de la habana se
enfrentan a la escasez de alimentos y al
aumento de sus precios el gobierno de
díaz canel aprobó el año pasado 63
medidas que prestan ayudar a los
campesinos pero esto no ha sido
suficiente para paliar las dificultades
aún hay falta de frutas y de carne de
cerdo vital en la dieta cubana las
autoridades parecen estar al tanto de la
situación la agricultura cubana dinero
podemos por no avanzar primero del
escaso desarrollo tecnológico y la
imposibilidad de desarrollarla
aquí hay tecnologías muy primitivas
y el segundo de la carencia de insumos
en el país gasta unos dos mil millones
de dólares anuales en la importación de
alimentos según las autoridades unos 800
millones podrían ahorrarse si se lograra
tecnificar el campo las cifras oficiales
apuntan a que en la isla el 49 por
ciento de las tierras agrícolas no son
cultivadas
y por primera vez desde 1998 se exhibe
el icónico autorretrato de la artista
mexicana frida kahlo llamado diego y yo
y se hace en el museo de arte
latinoamericano de buenos aires esta
obra además se convirtió en 2.021 en la
pieza latinoamericana de arte más
cotizada en subastas cuando el argentino
eduardo constantini fundador del museo
la compró por 34,9 millones de dólares
en nueva york ahora a partir de hoy la
obra de frida kahlo será el centro de la
exposición tercer ojo con la que
constantini mostrará su colección
privada
hasta que este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]